the only thing bigger than this man's
talent is his heart which I have seen on
display at the big slick in Kansas City
on behalf of Children's Mercy Hospital
this man is all about making the world a
better place whether it's through his
generosity or with his supreme talent on
Modern Family which is netted him awards
and I love him I don't care who knows it
III said it meant every word I just said
and I didn't want to go on a draft night
without talking to a man who will be
waiting around but doesn't care how long
he's waiting because that means the
Chiefs won the Superbowl he's Eric
Stonestreet how are you sir quick
question what would you do right now if
I punched you in the face
I didn't mind a question actually
what are you trying to glean from that I
think you're trying to glean how quick
he formulates an answer because it's
such a it's such a crazy question and
how he reacts to the question but then I
think you're also waiting to see how he
justifies his answer I think that's the
important thing of what he says so how
would you answer that question I would
say sir I would say are you asking as
you if I would punch you in the face as
my football coach because I would
restrain myself because I want your
family that to have you as their father
so I would restrain myself right now but
then you know I don't want to deprive
your children of growing up exactly what
you think you do to him without saying
good thing you just wouldn't do it
without also underselling your power
that you would pack would said punch
confidently I would I would beat the
living crap out of you yes but I'm not
going to I'm gonna do this I very rarely
do this with you but I'll do it Howard
cam from Modern Family answer that
question if being in oh yeah yeah I mean
I I think camera I think cam would say
first of all I love the question it was
a wonderful question and then I think he
would you would see the farm farm farm
farm strength come yesterday
moment dance straight the farm strength
would you know it's funny I was in
preparation for this interview Eric
because you know I'm a lead-pipe
wielding professional I was wondering
how long has Eric had to wait for a
first-round draft selection from the
Kansas Jews now what's the longest eric
has had to wait for a first-round draft
selection from the Kansas City Chiefs
what do you mean well I mean you're
gonna have to wait I mean your 32nd
overall you can't that's as that's as
deep as you can possibly get what I'm
just saying is how the Super Bowl
championship has brought you a long
first draft night and then I looked like
the last time the Chiefs made a
first-round draft selection was mahomes
that's the last time they made a
first-round draft selection we moved up
to get him yeah well we had that number
one pick a few years ago that was it we
weren't happy about having the number
one pick but I got fish there and I'm
excited about I mean it's it's it's a
weird place to be in as a fan that I'm I
have I love I love our draft right now
because of the volatility of the board
first of all not knowing who's gonna go
where they're gonna go I think like
brevete said there's gonna be a lot of
surprises so who knows who's going to be
available at 32 but just given the
coronavirus and the you know the the
situation that we're all going through
right you know the Chiefs are are locked
and loaded where our team is basically
what it was last year so we don't have
like the situation we had last year
where we wanted McCoy Hardman to come in
and contribute immediately and learn the
offense and learn the you know the
complicated schemes that Coach Reed
comes up with this year you know we're
not going to be asking that as much from
rookies right we don't need to right and
that that's why some might drop some
might not be you know taken by teams
because they aren't plug-and-play ready
and things of that nature but let's just
say the Chiefs don't trade out because
somebody might have traded up a little
bit sooner for for a player and the
Chiefs are like okay screw it we're just
gonna add somebody what do you what do
you want who do you want what do you
think well I think it's hard to say we
we would pass up a defensive back if if
the guy was there that we really liked I
mean you know I think there's a
if my sources are correct there's a
couple offensive guys and a couple
defensive guys that that we like that
they like sorry I'm not it's not we
talking like a general manager there's
some offensive and defensive players
does that mean that you're not
considering a punch or a kicker set 32nd
overall yeah I think we're gonna take
quarterback out of the equation right no
I I'm just excited because again this
this 32nd pick if we don't trade back
you know is only gonna contribute to the
team this year in my opinion I mean it's
not going to be it's not going to be a
developmental player and the other good
news is is that we can draft in the next
for the next couple years you know with
respect to like the offensive line
knowing that you know you're always need
a good tackle right always need a good
swing tackle so mm-hmm
I think you know that's a good prospect
for us too as far as just being able to
draft for the next couple years to keep
Patrick surrounded by weapons well I saw
in a couple of mocs that if deandre
swift of Georgia or JK Dobbins who I am
thrilled will no longer play another
down for the Ohio State University those
two running backs look pretty damn plug
and play ready for me and just to see
that that's the guy that they would add
after that we saw what the offense
looked like last year oh my gosh Eric
that yeah I would love to see that for
you
that's for sure yeah I like it too I
like our running back situation the kid
we just got from Texas Tech from the
Raiders and and obviously Williams what
Williams is on man Williams is a beast
he is no slouch there's no doubt I know
I know you can't do it no I just I I I
think linebacker that can move quick and
pursue cornerback those are those are
two and always defensive line I mean I
think we proved with our rotation last
year with the defensive line and other
teams are as well you know having a deep
defensive line is is crucial in the NFL
especially with these guys that
that you know Lamar and the and the and
the the running backs or the
quarterbacks that move around so well
Eric Stonestreet here on the Rich Eisen
show all right Eric did you see the the
photograph of Andy reads draft room have
you seen that yeah I don't know what my
favorite part of it is the most it's
clearly a basement because the the
windows are very high up yeah it looks
like he might be jamming a makeshift
desk up against two red doors I have no
idea what's on the other side of it you
have the picture up are you bringing the
picture up on the screen yeah we got it
right there Eric and then of course it
it there is there is a apparently some
sort of device that's used for
cardiovascular help that it does look
like he's using Eric and there's a big
deal there it is okay oh yeah look at
that I haven't seen the wide picture of
that I haven't seen that yeah yeah there
you go what do you think assess that for
me man let me tell you he is the best I
I was intimidated to be around him and
scared a little bit nervous to be around
him because of how much I respect what
he does and stuff like that but I've
broken through that and have can say now
I've gotten to spend some time with him
and he truly is everything you hear the
players and other personnel say about
him he's just a an all-world guy we have
a lot in common which is what's really
crazy because he grew up in here here in
LA and when he and I sit down and talk
we can have some of the same references
as far as like hot spots of getting a
good bite to eat in Los Angeles and we
we really correct ourselves up talking
about different different places to get
a good burger good a good burrito in Los
Angeles so are you also a grown-ass man
and upon passing cake contest back in
the day as a child I didn't look too
different than that you know I I was as
tall as I am now six one when I was in
seventh grade I stuck out like a sore
thumb a sore thumb and but he was he is
such a great that is such a great all
all were
of all time definitely a video of Coach
read so I just were just so lucky to
have him as our leader in Kansas City so
is it before I let you go Eric
is it true you have given roger goodell
pointers on what he should have as his
background for tonight's NFL never I
would never ever ever be so bold as to
give the Commissioner pointers I think
he is he is fully capable and has a
great team around him having said that
rich yes I did I told him like look man
you gotta just this is the embrace it
you know just embrace it you're in your
basement I don't know what that will
mean for for for Roger as you know and I
know and people don't like to hear
because they enjoy booing him instead
and thinking he's the worst human to
ever walk the face of the earth he's a
funny guy he's got a great sense of
humor he's a he's a kind individual to
people around him yes so I don't know
what it'll mean for him to embrace his
environment but I suggested you know
sweat pants and flip-flops and okay okay
I said I know you still have to be the
commissioner but I really want you to
have fun with being in your basement as
much as you possibly can embrace the
basement is what you told the council
embrace you know don't don't deny the
reality of where you are I'm sure it's a
nice basement but you know just enjoy
enjoy where you enjoy where you are he
he's told he's told me and the Wall
Street Journal words I've never said
before it's right off the laundry room
so maybe he could just be out there you
know that the the the Tennessee Titans
select as he's folding you know a shirt
or putting socks together and then he
announced the policy should be he should
be you know like sharing a concert and
have like five or ten wardrobe changes
changes well again he's right by the
laundry and I said it'd be really great
if you if when you come back from
commercial break you're not where you're
supposed to be and then you just clearly
have been too
something else but you know again he's
he's such a smart guy because he's
worried about anything you know like
coming off the wrong way he's he cares
about his job he cares about
representing these kids and he knows
it's these kids day so he wants to do
right by them and I know they're gonna
have some fun stuff in store for the the
you know the virtual Ness of when they
when the kids are picked Eric thanks for
the time man Congrats on that modern
family run 11 years - dude I mean the
amount of joy that you brought people
and the rest of the cast and the people
who rode you know what that means also
rich we've known each other 11 years
that's been that long are you serious 11
years oh yeah that's right you were one
of the first guys that I was like super
stoked to like get to meet and talk to
you because I was a fan of yours before
you know I was on family so when I
forget where we met at the for the first
time but yeah we've known each other 11
years we we have and I had one of the
first things I told you is I love your
show
your show is just and it didn't in and
and the amazing thing is had a Susie and
I my wife and I we would watch it all
time she's constantly watching reruns
laughing at the last episode as hard as
we did the first the entire time never
missed a beat all of it maybe you
haven't seen the last dimension cameras
who knows you never know it's perfect
what would you do right now if I punch
Chris in the face of Chris I'm telling
you this is what people think this is
what Andy's got the Lombardi right now
oh I've got six I can't hear what you
say
[Music]
they're done the delay on my TV is so
long I just now saw the look on Chris
cam in Tampa neighbors of Gronk or
Gisele and Tom and Gronk and and
Gasparilla and Ybor City in all of it oh
my god comics I'm excite excited for Tom
I'm excited too Rob I'm a fan of those
guys as athletes and I'm just really I'm
really pumped for the city of Tampa Bay
I just I think it's I think it's it's
it's a great new beginning for them a
bread crumb and a laugh that's what we
just got the friend Eric Stonestreet
Fant
take right back after that Eric
Stonestreet oh my gosh talk about comic
timing I give him that introduction he
comes right in what a for rich question
what if I punched you right in the face
he said they'll Tufo did he give a bread
crumb and then just cuz I mean he's just
been wait he was cultivating them ready
to just throw the Brady and Gronk thing
in the face the Patriot fan here oh that
was just chefs kiss as always perfect
timing
by the way I would see a Mitch in camp
show tomorrow yes tonight no I mean
tonight's the try it
I would consume such a program 8 4 4 2
Oh for rich number $2.00 your phone
calls and not one but two last general
manager home draft rooms that we have
cultivated that's next on the Rich Eisen
show
[Music]
that was great I mean didn't see that
coming he's so quick
you can't yeah you got always know he's
thinking I mean I've had my fun Eric's
expense oh my gosh beard so you kidding
that was fantastic
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here